how to set film Solutions into your Sony
camera first of all you need to find the
picture profile menu in most cases
there's a custom button assign to it but
if not you have to find it in the deeper
menu on the newest cameras it'll be an
exposure color menu then go to color
tone hit okay on the picture profile and
you have all picture profile slots laid
out but this is on the new Sony A700 on
older cameras it'll be that color wi
balance and image processing which can
be found either in the movie icon or the
image icon finally enter the picture
profile and hit right on the dial to see
the deeper menu now you can add your
film simulation settings and get amazing
color straight out of camera
enjoy